[Music]
Simon I'm curious you seem to get
stronger when the crowd boos you when a
crowd turns on you you your powers seem
to grow you seem to enjoy it is that
true it is it's like oxygen radios try
booing me right now that's the kind of a
warmth
I was looking you right there I've never
seen anyone happier you were just you
were being ladled it's smothered in
booze and you were perfectly happy with
sins they care you know when we do these
auditions and I think the first time
that I'm in Brittany in particular the
first because there's a lot of people in
the arenas where you do these auditions
in the first times you said no to
someone she got booed and she just
freaked out over a Minj she wasn't used
to being me yeah I did like it and the
same with this one
yeah I got I did I got booed a lot cuz
you know I learned the first thing that
I learned when I got on the show is just
don't be influenced by any other
person's opinions of what you think of
the contestant so I went in there and I
literally just spoke what was on my mind
and they didn't like to hear it and so I
got booed and I was at first I was like
oh my god I know how Simon feels and
then I was like oh my god but he doesn't
care and I do but then you got used to
it there's still some part of you that
dies every time when you hear that
booing and you at like I say you enjoy
it you love it you relish it you'd
rather be booed than cheered well I get
boo-booed more than I get shits that you
have to get used to it yeah okay let me
ask you about this hmm
the world's tiniest violin playing would
you like anything you just want to go I
like it there there's all this time
[Laughter]
there's all this talk about Brittany
walking off the set of x-factor is that
true and if so why well she likes to
have a break Abby what 20 minutes so we
can do kind of like four or five
auditions and then she likes to go to a
dressing room for five or ten minutes
then she comes back out again you do the
same thing oh oh you do it as well as
well you don't you read about you read
about Brittany all the time leaving the
set and you and it's written about and
you'd do the same thing what are you
doing in your dressing room every 20
minutes
a cigarette oxygen tank oxygen mom a
hyperbaric chamber
I actually I used one rethinking the
blood of Christians you know